تويتر العصفور الازرق حتى الان مازال يحلق
في سماء مواقع التواصل برغم من هجره
الرافدين لسياسه الملك الجديد الى النصر
الموظفين مخاوف من انتشار خطابات متشدده
مرورا بمعارضه نموذج الاشتراكات المدفوعه
اذا الى اين يلجا المهاجرون من تويتر وما
هو حجم حركه الهجره هذه
هناك عده بدائل بدات تزدهر في الايام
الاخيره لكن تبدو من الصد سكاي وعاده
للغايه رغم انها نتزال في مرحله التجريبيه
30,000 مشترك انضموا لهذه المنصه خلال
يومين فقط مدفوعين بشغا في تجربه شبكه
تواصل جديده بقياده جاك دورسي المؤسس
المدير التنفيذي السابق تويتر نتعرف على
المزيد معك يا لميس
تويتر تحت قياده ماسك حاله انهيار ام كما
يقال انها بدايه جديده بامكانيات اكثر
وشكل جديد واتساع لحريه الراي والتعبير
لكن مع حاله التخبط هناك منصات تنتظر
الفرصه لتحل مكانه
اصبحت تحقق شعبيته متسارعه للتجاوز
المليون المشترك وذلك حسب مؤسسها الالماني
ليجن روشكو بواقي 490 الف مستخدم جديد منذ
استحواذي ماسك على تويتر ايضا اشياء اخرى
تثير الفضول بينها شبكات كونتر
سوشيال التي اطلقها التي اطلقها دونالد
ترامب تقدم نفسها في الاساس على انها
بدائل عن تويتر لكن تبدو من سكاي بديلا
قويا تويتر وهي التي انشاها احد مؤسسات
تويتر عام 2022
واعلن اكثر من 30,000 شخص على قائمه
الانتظار
كان نفسه على انه تطبيق تواصل اجتماعي لا
مركزي يتيح للمستخدم التحكم في خوارزمياته
والسيطره على بياناتهم بشكل كامل
[موسيقى]
في الاستوديو ينضم لنا الاستاذ الجامعه
والمستنشر في اداره الاعمال الالكترونيه
الدكتور انس النجلاوي دكتور اهلا بك يسعد
صباحك
المعارضون والغاضبون من تغييرات ماسك في
تويتر يبحثون عن بدائل اخرى اين الى اين
حركه الهجره هجده المعارضين ما هي ابرز
البدائل المطروح اليوم صباح الخير
يعني
التركيز على تويتر هي بالسابق على الكثير
من المشاكل يعني ليست والده اليوم لكن
طبعا يعني التركيز الاعلامي على تويتر
وعلى قضيه الاستحواذ هنالك تطبيقات كثيره
مشابهه لتويتر مليئه في الانترنت ولكن
اكثر شهره ما هو الذي همم فلوس كاي التي
سوف طبعا همم يقوم بادارتها المدير السابق
لتويتر تورسي وهي تقوم على ثوره جديده في
طريقه عمل السوشيال ميديا وليس فقط يعني
نسخ مط او مشابهه لتويتر لانه الانترنت
مليء مليئه بالتطبيقات المشابهه لهذه
السوشيال ميديا مثل تويتر دونالد ترامب
عنده منصه همم صحيح والتي هي فقط محصوره
في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وتشبه بشكل
كثير اليه عمل لكنها لم تنجح همم السر هو
الظهور الظهور الى الظهور ما يسمى بديشن
او التطبيقات اللامركزيه
طيب دكتور انس هل المستخدمون يبالغون
اليوم بانتقاد تويتر يعني انا كمستخدمه
لما اتاثر حتى الان من المالك الجديد من
الجهه هل فقط من ينتقد والمتاثر فقط
الموظفون في التويتر عالميا واقلاميا في
الشركات
الكبيره لموظفين تويتر
اداره المحتوى همم طبعا الان تاتي كثير من
الهجمات انه هذا سوف يزيد خطاب الكراهيه
وسوف يزيد يعني هنالك ضوابط اقل من اجل
اداره المحتوى طبعا هذا ما يصير قلق همم
يعني همم الاشخاص المعارضين في الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه بسبب انه قد تنتشر بعض
الافكار وقد تنتشر دكتور يعني علامه
التوثيق الزرقاء كانت اكثر ما اثار غضب
مستخدم تويتر خاصه يستخدمها كل ما يدفع
ويحصل على هذه العلامه وبالتالي ظهور
حسابات مضلله ووهميه يعني مثيره للقلق هل
يمكن من السطات اخرى ان تقدم نفس الميزات
التي كانت لتويت وترضي مستخدمي ومحبي
تويتر للتوجه اليها
التوثيق هي فقط هي من اجل الارباح يعني
مباشره وهي بدون هناك كثير من يعني
المشاكل
واتوقع انه سوف يتم التراجع عن هذه الاليه
لانها ليس لا تضمن بشكل كبير التوثيق
التوثيق يحتاج الى تقنيات اكبر ومعقده
اكثر من تطبيقات وتقنيات البلوكشن وانا
برايي الابحاث ما زالت قائمه بشكل كبير من
اجل تقليل ما يسمى الفايك نيوز او انتشار
همم الاخبار المضلله وهذا طبعا لحد الان
لا نجدهم 100% صراحه في ايام منصه همم
وبالتالي همم اذا اردت ان تضبط 100% سوف
تعدم الحريه واذا اردت ان تسمح المجال
للحريه سوف تنتشر الكثير العمل ما زال
قائما والابحاث ما زالت جاريه في صناعه ما
يسمى نيو انترنت بروتوكولز وهذا ما يقوم
به الان جاك دورسي بحيث انه يعني يسمح
بالحريه
سيطره من قبل الافراد على معلوماتهم
وبياناتهم ولكن نحتاج الى صراحه الى اليات
اكبر من اجل السيطره على المعلومات
المضلله ما زالت المجال واسع للابحاث
والتطوير صراحه
كتب في تغريده ودائما تغريداته لافته
للنظر كتب احب حين يشتكي الناس على تويتر
على تويتر
طب اليوم بين بلو سكاي طب جاك دورسي
المؤسسه السابق وبين بلو بيرد ان صح
التعبير اليوم كيف راح تكون منافسه
التوجه كله بالمستقبل نحو
انا طبعا تنبات بهذا الموضوع
تذهب نحو تطبيقات البلوكين وهي تسمح به
نوع من الشفافيه لكن بنفس الوقت عدم
التلاعب بالمعلومات والبيانات وهذا
التطبيق وهذا البروتوك همم ارى انه سوف
ينجح بشكل اكبر لان الناس خلاص زهقت من
الاجزاءت من السبانز والروبوتات التي تنشر
المعلومات المضلله والسيطره المركزيه يعني
هذا شيء اتوقع انه غير مستمر ولا يكون
دائم يعني بصراحه المنافسه التقنيات
الجديده
شكرا دكتور شكرا دكتور